buenas tardes
nací en colonia del sacramento cuando
colonia era una clásica ciudad del
interior con casas grandes fondos
amplios y muchos terrenos baldíos
entonces se hacía muy fácil estar en
contacto con la actividad deportiva que
tanto preocupaba a los padres y nos
preocupa hasta hoy en día lleva la
escuela de mañana volvía almorzaba
rápidamente hacia los deberes más rápido
todavía y después me dijo en las
bicicletas a buscar aventuras por el
barrio y se me hacía muy fácil
encontrarlas donde en los famosos
terrenos baldíos en los potreros en las
canchitas que abundaban en aquel
entonces y abundaban niños jugando al
fútbol entonces dejaban la bicicleta te
metías y ahí nacía el jugador de fútbol
no nos encontraban la verdad niños
jugando al básquetbol o al béisbol se
jugaban la pelota y todos que soñábamos
con ser jugadores de fútbol y se armaron
los partidos espectaculares y disfruté
mucho
esa etapa en mi vida en colonia pero
había un momento duro difícil complicado
que era cuando llegaba el verano
llegaron las vacaciones
y como toda ciudad del interior colonia
se apagaba al mediodía los comercios
cerrados y los padres iban a cenar a
casa a almorzar a la casa de uno y se
terminaba la comida y te decían bueno al
cuarto y hasta las cuatro de la tarde no
puede salir porque arrancaba la hora
sagrada de la ciudad que era la siesta
y no era la hora porque se decía a la
hora de la siesta pero vos miraba el
reloj y te encontrabas con que eran la
una y media y te tenía que quedar
encerrado en tu dormitorio hasta las
cuatro y no podías hacer ruido y papá me
aburro mamá mauro los problemas tuyos
tan del cuarto y de rata y no haga
rabietas y ahí empezaba la creación de
uno la imaginación obviamente en los
dormitorios no había televisión no había
internet no había wifi no existían los
celulares
simplemente había una cama placares y
arréglate como puedas entonces uno
empezaba a hacer como una especie de
macgyver durante esas horas de fiesta y
tenía que empezar a inventar y a ver qué
hacer y había muy poquito juguete
también tampoco era los juguetes que hay
hoy día habían muy poquito es de hecho
yo creo que había tan solo una pelota y
nada más y empezamos a hurgar y aver
placares abrir este cajones y fue ahí
donde tuve mi primer encuentro cara a
cara con la lectura porque se hacía tan
larga la siesta esa tarde
que empezaba a salir y me acuerdo que
encontré un gráfico un gráfico viejo de
la revista el gráfico que era sería de
mi padre y lo leí y después revisando
por ahí de diferentes lugares
encontré una patrocinó también encontré
un libro de elige tu propia aventura que
me encantó y un día con apenas 10 años
encontré un libro de un autor llamado
stephen king que había escrito una
novela llamada cojo de un perro asesino
que bueno contraía la rabia y conoce
años empecé a leer a ese perro asesino y
me encantó y viaje un alucine con él y
ahí se comenzó a despertarse el interés
por la lectura pero siempre pasó lo
mismo
leía fantasía leía literatura de adultos
leía historietas superiores pero nunca
encontré quizás lo había pero yo nunca
encontré ni mi infancia y mi
adolescencia un personaje que yo pudiera
identificarme con él y sintiera que
podía
es el protagonista de esa historia
cuando pase al liceo seguir jugando al
fútbol seguir leyendo e incorpore
el deseo de inventar historias y
describir esos personajes que la verdad
me hacían falta sentí a ese joven que
tuviera mis miedos mis desencantos mis
frustraciones y cuando empecé a escribir
me di cuenta que me hacía bien que era
como una liberación inventar una
historia
de un personaje que fuese parecido a mí
y que viviera lo mismo que estaba
viviendo yo en aquel entonces que
obviamente por ejemplo han elegido
siempre me gustó la más linda de la
clase y nunca me dio bolilla pero yo
llegaba a mi casa inventaba una historia
que ella esa persona me llamaba y me si
adán y que tienes que hacer el sabadell
o necesidad nada pero que conocía que
iba a salir a tomar algo ella lloraba y
cortaba y nunca me va a salir conmigo
entonces porque en el instante en que
estaba haciendo la historia yo me sentía
el galán de turno después volvía a mi
cruda realidad
pero me hacía bien y después empecé a
escribir novelas que me gusta un poquito
más que cuentos seguía jugando al fútbol
es incorporar mí también otra pasión que
fue la música y comencé clases de
batería y soñaba también con con armar
un día alguna banda de rock porque
escuchaba mucho los ramones y me
encerraba en mi cuarto y trataba de
poner la radio abajo de la frazada y así
imponía todo lo quedado en mi madre
dejaba eso que es esa locura bueno y
aquatica cuarto año de liceo y un día se
presenta a mi madre ante mí y me dice
danny viste qué
qué bueno estás terminando cuarto el año
que viene
te tenés que empezar a definir un poco
que quieres hacer de tu vida qué pensás
estudiar yo le digo mamá mira hay tres
cosas que me gustan mucho y me gustaría
hoy o mañana desempeñarme en ellas y
ella como que puso una sonrisa y dijo
que bueno tres cosas
y sería mirar una mamá es me encanta el
fútbol miro fútbol practicó fútbol
soñaría con hoy mañana sueño con el
mañana entrar a una cancha y ser jugador
de fútbol profesional y vivir de eso
dijo ella
bien buenísimo bueno seguir practicando
vamos a ver qué pasa y las otras dos mi
amor bueno mira la segunda es viste que
me gusta mucho la música voy a clases de
batería bueno me encantaría mañana tiene
una banda de rock toca la batería
la sonrisa fue como que se le achicó un
poquito más y la tercera mi amor con
cierta ilusión en su mirada y le digo
mira mamá me di cuenta últimamente que
estoy escribiendo historias y que me
encantaría ser escritor
pero qué piensas hacer de tu vida y fue
con las mamás tres cosas te dije cuántas
que eres y fue como que esa rebeldía
adolescente que todos deberíamos tener
me impulsó a tratar de ganarles a pulsar
yo le quiero mucho a llamame de estar
mirando trauma más este y me impulsó a
decir por qué no hacer ninguna de estas
tres cosas qué pasa si si lucho por
ellas y se me
la primera pulseada la ganó cuando plaza
colonia me hace firmar mi primer
contrato profesional bastante joven
y bueno fue como que viste mamá tan
equívoca igual éste cobraba 2 chirola no
me hagas año para comprar una camisa
pero bueno estaba al menos este no me
podía independizar entonces seguía tenía
así así que seguir teniendo una buena
relación con mis padres igual estaba
mi papá y después bueno me llegó
el pase si finalmente al cruz azul de
méxico bastante temprano y me fui a
méxico y ahí vieron y bueno pero de
todas maneras siempre me apoyan a todos
y ahí fue que me fui a méxico pero nunca
renuncié a mis otras pasiones de hecho
nunca me creí y me gustó eso de que
tiene que ser esto y nada más
de hecho me imaginaba y con mucha razón
que el fútbol se me iba a terminar
bastante temprano en la vida y tenía que
seguir explorando otros mundos porque si
no que iba a ser cuando terminaran y me
acuerdo cuando arme la valija para
para ir a méxico puse ropa puse libros
que quería leer y la computadora donde
escribía y yo iba a entrenar en la
mañana al cruz azul éste volvía y
almorzaba me ha costado dormir una
siesta después me levantaba y me ponía a
leer y escribir que era más o media
escuchaba y siempre con la música de
fondo siempre fueron las cosas que me
gustaron hacer y que más o menos bueno
logré ser bien salvo la música y soy un
desastre pero bueno finalmente me
terminó contando con una música y
tenemos dos hijas con ella así que
martina
y entonces un día cuando ya llevaba como
seis años como futbolista profesional
me animé un poco también por la
insistencia de mis amigos de aquellos
valientes que se habían animado a leer
algo de lo que había escrito y fui y lo
dejé en una editorial a ver qué me
decían y la primera crítica que obtuve
de las editoriales fue mirar está bueno
no te vamos a decir que no estamos
viendo lo que escribís pero lo dirige
mucho a un público
qué es un fracaso
si es un fracaso porque escribes mucho
para jóvenes para adolescentes y ese
público no lector entonces no vas a
vender un libro
acá hay dos dos mundos en las
editoriales para explorar qué es el
adulto que vende lo suyo y el infantil
que también vende y luego justo mucho
ojo yo pero es justo lo que me faltaba a
mí es lo que lo que me motivaba a
escribir es lo que me dicen que no vende
y me terminaron publicando igual una
historia muy linda se llama la botella
fc y de usted como escritor digamos en
librerías y es una historia infantil y
yo seguía con lo millón de hecho en mi
época de creación por ejemplo tengo un
libro que se llama estadio lleno donde
un niño sufre la obsesión del padre
porque sea jugador de fútbol y lo lleva
al fútbol lo hace ver fútbol le compra
zapatos de fútbol le compra todo de
fútbol le habla de fútbol y en realidad
lo que él quiere es el músico cuando se
lo expresa el papá papá le dice pero no
seas bobo no vas a comparar ser famoso
jugar al fútbol esté con los músicos son
los vagos que se mueren de hambre y lo
escucha así como que me estás diciendo
pues bueno el acusado cuando cumple 18
años le surge finalmente la posibilidad
de firmar su primer contrato profesión
como futbolista
y el papá ya está festejando de que
tiene el sueño de su vida un hijo
futbolista profesional se le va a dar al
mismo tiempo le surge la posibilidad ir
a estudiar música de cada francia
mientras el papá está festejando el 10 y
papá y será tu sueño en el mío me voy a
ir a francia me surge esta posibilidad y
se pelea con el papá la cuestión de se
toma el avión iba a estudiar música
francia y le va a sufrir bastante y en
el medio conoce a una chica más joven
mayor que él y un día ella vivía sola lo
lleva al apartamento y el apartamento no
se pueden admirar netflix ver los
cuadros del apartamento y agregar las
flores sino que tiene su primera
relación sexual
obviamente no alguna vez capaz que nos
pasó a los que estamos acá y entonces en
la editorial me decían y qué hacemos con
este capítulo perdón con este capítulo
que hay una relación sexual
y los jóvenes no tienen relaciones
sexuales pero ese capítulo me pasó
también con un libro que tengo que se
llama los meses un verdadero equipo
donde habla de jóvenes y que uno tiene
problemas con la droga otro tiene
problemas con el alcohol
y
y todo ese mundo oscuro que hay detrás
de los jóvenes muchas veces que tenemos
nosotros como autos esa barrera de que
nos incomoda hablar de ciertas cosas y
me sé que este es como que el tema de
las adicciones tiene un peso muy fuerte
al libro sí porque tiene un peso muy
fuerte en los jóvenes de día
y también tenía otra historia
que se llama mi mundial
que habla de un niño que también viene
de un lugar de mucha pobreza y que
parece que la única salvación de él y de
su familia es el fútbol lo es un genio
con la pelota lo van a ver a una ciudad
en interior a colonia justamente
increíblemente en este y lo traen lo
traen acercamos a montevideo y le dan un
apartamento muy lujoso un representante
le da plata a los padres porque los
padres tienen que renunciar a su trabajo
para acompañarlo
y en un momento cuando vos decís que
bueno para triunfar tiene un accidente
se rompe la pata no puedes ir cuando al
fútbol y vuelve a la pobreza en la que
había salido y todavía con la mochila de
la frustración y de la reinserción
social sin la gallina el huevo de ver
que era el fútbol en ese week y todo lo
que vive con los padres de del hecho de
del maltrato de los representantes de
quesos descartables como mejor de fútbol
son descartables cuando puedes dar
dinero o servicio cuando no no entonces
cuando cuando ven eso el impacto que
tenía ese final y el impacto que iba a
generar en los lectores en los jóvenes
me lo quisieron cambiar y me dijeron
mira de este final no es nada comercial
o sea es como una tristeza absoluta cómo
termina el libro yo si me cambia este
final el libro no sale
gracias a una editora que
y al editorial santillana estoy muy
agradecido que se animaron a sacarlo al
libro con muchos miedos de saber cuál
era la reacción
nos dimos cuenta de algo
los jóvenes estaban esperando este tipo
de cosas y no quieren superhéroes no
quieren mundos de fantasías quieren
protagonistas que sufran y sientan lo
mismo que ellos y que ellos se pueden
identificar que sean el espejo de ellos
el libro vendió en tan solo dos años
alrededor de 60.000 ejemplares en
uruguay es un numero exorbitado
después sacaron los meses y un verdadero
equipo gracias a esto y enseguida los
jóvenes no sólo lo leían sino que
debatíamos y el ida y vuelta era lo que
me enriquecí a más mi mundial se fue de
uruguay se publicó en argentina se
publicó en perú se publicó en paraguay
en paraguay aparte es un libro de texto
o sea en el manual de educación de
cuarto año de las escuelas de paraguay
tienen que ver mi mundial también está
en méxico también me llamaron de una
productora de cine salió la película y
no sólo fue la segunda película más
taquillera en la historia del cine
uruguayo sino que también está rodando
por todo el planeta con esto que quiero
decir que la tengo clara no la tengo
clara ni ahí porque tengo rotundos
fracasos y me he dado de bomba contra
una pared muchísimas veces pero que
quiero decir es que si en algo tenía
pasión que los jóvenes quieren leer que
muchas veces somos nosotros los que
tenemos miedo de esas edades y que no
sabemos muchas veces cómo llegarles y
cómo
y lograr que ellos nos acepten y no hay
que tener miedo hay que mostrar nuestras
virtudes y nuestros defectos también
porque no somos ningunos superhéroes y
he tenido a lo largo de mi carrera como
escritor varios reconocimientos y bueno
algunos premios pero me quedo con esa
ida y vuelta justamente y este año me
paso y para terminar este qué
bien el técnico de una de un equipo de
fútbol y me cuenta que también le da
clases a niños que están viviendo en un
hogar que sufrió en violencia doméstica
entonces lo sacan y los llevan a vivir
ahí tienen educadores y demás y él
siempre como técnico de fútbol
igualmente hacía mucho hincapié
en que lean y que traten de tener buenas
calificaciones de hecho otro de los
proyectos que yo realice y que al
principio me decían pero eso es loco
nadie va a leer era porque dicen que no
leen cya no les damos libros porque no
meter libros en los clubes de fútbol y
por suerte hay un señor no sé si lo
conocen llama oscar washington tabárez
que fue el primero que me dijo danielle
eso es muy importante quiero que lo
traigas acá a la selección de fútbol al
complejo de uruguay porque es necesario
que haya bibliotecas en los clubes de
fútbol muchas gracias maestro y después
de ahí lo replique en otros clubes creo
que eso es muy importante pero entonces
este técnico de este club este
a este niño en particular le había
repetido quinto año de escuela y juegan
muy bien
y le preguntaba por qué repetir tenemos
porque no me interesa la escuela yo
quiero jugar a la pelota que es el
jugador de fútbol al otro año pasó
quinto año con apenas bueno al final de
año y sigue con el mismo discurso el año
pasado repitió sexto año
y también que no quería estudiar que
quería jugar el fútbol y este año hace
15 días y todavía es
no puedo evitar a veces emocionarme
donde pasan estas cosas
llevo el carné con las calificaciones y
tenía todo muy bueno sobresaliente y
algunos sobresalientes también entonces
este el técnico le pregunta
a qué se debe este cambio en vos no
porque siempre traía su mano regularon
bueno y ahora estás en casi un
sobresaliente y se lo pasó al señor que
el año pasado vi la película mi mundial
y este año
leí el libro y me di cuenta que la única
forma que tengo de cumplir mis sueños es
estudiando muchas gracias
[Música]